what if morality is just a fiction used
by the herd of inferior human beings to
hold back the few superior men
in this sprout special with stephen
hicks we examine nietzsche's explanation
for how ethics develop and the
consequences for master types living in
a world that's dominated by the morality
of a slave
[Music]
part three
master slave morality and the origin of
the bad conscience
nietzsche argued that there are two
explanations for how morality develops
part of the story is biopsychological in
terms of what morality resonates with
what psychological type of person one is
the other part of the story is cultural
because different moral codes develop
under different survival circumstances
and so nietzsche searches history for
the survival circumstances that
necessitated the development of slave
morality
in the west nietzsche finds the slave
morality's roots in the judeo-christian
tradition in a decisive set of events
that occurred early in jewish history
the enslavement of the jews in egypt the
significant result of the jews being
enslaved for a long time was the
development and internalization of a
moral code suitable for surviving
slavery
suppose that you are a slave how do you
survive and if you have children who are
born into slavery what survival
strategies will you teach them
in order to survive a slave must obey
the master this does not come naturally
so the first lesson is you must stifle
your nature
[Music]
suppose the master strikes you the
desire for revenge comes naturally but
you have to stifle it
suppose the master tells you to wait
being inactive does not come naturally
but you must suppress your desire for
activity
suppose the master tells you to do
something you do not want to do
you must override your desire to do what
you want and obey
generalizing you must train yourself to
restrain your natural impulses and to
internalize a humble patient obedient
self
you know you must do this because slaves
who do not end up dead
consequently nietzsche asserts slave
virtues have survival value
obedience humility forgiveness and
patience are good for slaves and those
are the traits slaves will drill into
their children if they want them to
survive
over time the slave virtues become
cultural values
in every generation many people are
sheep-like and do not especially mind
being slaves but others resent it and
here the story nietzsche tells becomes
darker
in order to survive they must direct
their natural strength and assertiveness
against the expression of their own
strength and assertiveness
this naturally leads them to resent the
master strongly but they also start to
hate themselves for doing what the
master says and for their own role in
suppressing themselves
psychologically hating oneself causes
unbearable pressure inside because the
outward discharge of the instinct gets
inhibited and turned backward against
man himself
hostility cruelty joy and destruction
all this turned against the possessors
of such instincts
that is the origin of the bad conscience
hatred of the strong self-hatred and
revenge fantasies to ease the pain
become the lived psychological reality
of such slaves
make this psychological reality a matter
of months and years and the results will
be ugly and poisonous
[Music]
more provocatively nietzsche argues that
such slave individuals who feel the
internal war most strongly become the
social leaders of the slaves that is to
say they become their priests
it is because of their impotence that in
them hatred grows to monstrous
proportions
in their leadership role it is the
priests who most strongly advocate
meekness humility and obedience and who
condemn the aggressive strength and
pride of the masters
the priests are not in a position to use
physical power against the masters
instead the priests develop and use
morality as their weapon of
confrontation
[Music]
in the judeo-christian tradition slave
morality becomes part of a revenge
strategy
its point is to enable the weaker to
survive in a harsh world but also to
undermine the master types confidence in
themselves and eventually bring down the
masters so as to exact to spiritual
revenge
so
strength aggression weakness resentment
is morality really about us getting
along together in the world or is it
really a tool of power a survival
strategy and a way for the losers to
strike back against the successful
those are the hard questions nietzsche
makes us live with
what are your thoughts on morality do
you agree with nietzsche
for more information to reach stephen
hicks full account of the german
philosopher or to download this video
without background music check the
descriptions below
[Music]
this and all other sprouts videos are
licensed under creative commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do
to learn how it works and download this
video without ads or background music
check out our website or read the
description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education visit our patreon
that's patreon.com
sprouts